we sort of haven't talked in a way about
the war on christmas which doesn't exist
for a while
because there was a republican in office
so let me refresh your memory as to how
the war on christmas works it doesn't
actually exist
but now there's a democrat in office so
fox news wants to fully resurrect the
war on christmas when a republican is in
office
as president
the story is democrats want to wage the
war on christmas but thankfully we've
got a republican president so they're
not going to succeed that's the story
when a republican president is in office
when there's a democratic president in
office the story is the full war on
christmas routine the left wants to
cancel christmas they want it to be
illegal to say christmas they want it to
be illegal to be christian they don't
want gifts they don't want anything okay
this year
the war on christmas under a democratic
president is combining with the
possibility of supply chain issues
delaying christmas gifts and so dr fauci
is being taken out of context when he
was asked
last week or the week before about large
christmas gatherings uh it's all being
ramped up and kind of rolled together
now here's a little compilation we will
play
this is from the recount very nicely
done the supply chain crunch that
threatens to spoil the holiday season
there will be things that people can't
get toys not getting shipped
toys like tonka trucks tonka trucks
tonka trucks yeah uh my little pony
character is the type of things that
make or break a christmas
care bears tonka trunks my little honey
we've showed you the kind of trek from
the care bear in a factory in china to
the store in massachusetts well this is
the togetherness care bear and everybody
needs to be together and everybody needs
a hug they're going to be
harder to find if people can't get bacon
and people can't get a tonka toy that
would be joey
yeah that would be that would just be
terrible for joe biden so then the house
republicans tweeted a picture of joe
biden with the caption quote
this is the guys
who is trying to steal christmas
americans are not going to let that
happen
uh and i i know it shouldn't be but it's
still shocking to me that people
continue to fall for this stuff
a headline while peter ducey was
reporting from the white house read
toy association
ceo says it may be too late to save
christmas then at another moment when
peter ducey was reporting it said white
house scrambles as supply crisis
threatens christmas
neil cavuto had an explosive story with
an interview even called christmas tree
sellers hit by supply chain delays and
then on the opinion shows
i know right on the opinion shows laura
ingram had a story called the biden who
stole christmas
sean hannity then ran an almost
identical story called the grinch who
stole christmas but there's a picture of
joe biden in a green suit and tie
yesterday morning there was a segment on
unfiltered with dan bongino that might
be a fox news online show maybe it's an
actual tv show on the weekends i don't
know
the segment was called how the biden
administration is stealing christmas
aaron rupar reported on thursday last
week that fox news mentioned christmas
at least 106 times in the prior 24 hours
this is sort of like the epitome
of the cultural replacing the
substantive for the american right wing
we've talked about it before
this particular story the whole war on
christmas thing goes back to bill
o'reilly and some of those types in the
early 2000s they started this in the way
that it exists now they started it in
the early 2000s saying christmas is
being banned saying merry christmas is
being banned it's an attack on
christianity they're trying to diminish
christianity etc
the re the real genesis of this story is
that there were some companies that
decided to be marginally more inclusive
by saying hey you know what
let's say happy holidays
that that's basically the story and
everybody was fine and life continued
and it was no big deal but that was what
started what is now known as the war on
christmas and now just perfectly supply
chain issues melding with it dr fauci's
comments about christmas which by the
way will follow up on on today's bonus
show he's saying if you're vaccinated
it's probably fine to gather actually
that blended into it and now fox news is
utterly determined
to resurrect this war on christmas
incredible but they're succeeding this
is the type of stuff that does well it
gets ratings it gets people angry the
same way we've got to stop socialism
really what is socialism no it's biden
what
yeah it works it works and they have no
policy and that's why they're doing it
and you're already seeing war on
christmas stuff show up
it's it's it was early october when it
started
it's already there and now it's building
in all the usual online enclaves
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely free
service at
privacy.com pacman i've been using
privacy for a little over a year now
you've heard me talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plug-in
let you give each company a randomized
virtual credit card number that you
create out of thin air it'll even
autofill the card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account without the merchant
ever knowing your real information so
this allows you to keep your banking
information secure but also to take
control of your finances you can create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them you can delete them
anytime you want so when you do this it
means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be because you
can destroy the virtual card number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over if i use a virtual credit card
number you're keeping your identity
private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or credit card
info protected against data breaches and
identity theft and it's free there's no
catch whatsoever but if you want privacy
also offers a ten dollar a month plan
that gives you one percent cash back and
lets you create 36 credit cards a month
and a 25 a month plan tailored more for
small businesses where you can create 60
card numbers a month and much more but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like i
said you'll get five dollars to spend
when you sign up at privacy.com
slash pacman